l' enquête sur la profanation du
cimetière juif de carpentras froid des
auteurs présumés sont ce soir devant un
juge à marseille une partie du palais de
justice de bastia détruite cette nuit
par un incendie d'origine encore
indéterminée à l'elysée déjeuner tête à
tête jacques chirac edouard balladur
première rencontre depuis l'élection
présidentielle pour réaliser 20
milliards d'économies budgétaires le
gouvernement va tailler dans le système
z al embauche dernier titre fin du
voyage d'hervé de charette alger la
france entend prendre un nouveau départ
avec dale jr voilà monsieur bonsoir
avant de développer tous ces titres le
dicton du jour à la saint-alphonse et
patricia girard qui fonce cet athlète de
guadeloupéen de 28 ans s'est en effet
offert cette nuit un bonheur tout à fait
inattendue en remportant je vais te
lanta la médaille de bronze du 100 m
haies médaille obtenue au terme d'un
suspens insoutenable pour la départager
de l'américaine gyver ce pour un petit
centième de seconde il a fallu attendre
la photo l'électronique à patricia
girard qui s'offrent le luxe d'éliminer
donc du podium la championne du monde en
titre dans l'actualité en france les
suites de l'enquêté sur la profanation
du cimetière juif de carpentras en 90
trois des auteurs présumés de cette
promenade profanations ont été présentés
à ce soir un juge marseillais
d'autre part un militaire de carrière
interpellé hier soir à colmar aurait
avoué avoir participé à l'exhumation du
corps de félix germond albon milk aussi
il s'appelle yani il est employé dans
une société de surveillance à avignon en
garde à vue depuis mardi soir
il est le premier à avoir reconnu faire
partie des profanateurs qu'ils ont
dévasté le cimetière de carpentras il y
a 6 ans vers 15h cet après midi ils
quittent l'hôtel de police d'avignon
c'est son témoignage qui a relancé
l'enquêté fatiguée de porter un secret
trop lourd
il a passé des aveux précis et
circonstanciés
une heure plus tard il arrive au palais
de justice de marseille pour y être
entendue par le juge
instruction est probablement mis en
examen c'est lui qui a donné le nom de
ses acolytes qui l'ont suivi dans la
soirée le même chemin d'avignon à
marseille et puis nouveau rebondissement
vers 19h à mulhouse cette fois-ci ou un
militaire de carrière olivier âgé de 27
ans a lui aussi reconnu avec force
détails sa participation faits devant
les enquêteurs de la pj en 1990 il
effectué son service militaire en
allemagne
il devrait être transféré demain matin à
marseille l'annnonce de ces
interpellations a provoqué des réactions
mitigées parmi les habitants de
carpentras qui ont vécu depuis plus de
six ans au rythme des rumeurs les plus
folles et des fausses pistes même si
c'est le soulagement qui domine très
largement chez toutes les personnes
directement concernées par ce drame
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux
valérie et 8 raymond châtelard pas un
journal qui n'est titre sur
l'arrestation des profanateurs
carpentras pendant six ans otage de
cette affaire pourra-t-elle enfin
respirer se libérer de toutes ces
rumeurs et accusations qui ont circulé
dans la vidéo si la vérité celle qui est
annoncée
ça sera un désaveu d'abord pour ce
qu'ils ont fait ces accusations et puis
aussi pour une certaine forme de lüthi
spectacle si ce sont bien eux
à partir de ce moment là effectivement
cela color d'une hauteur tout à fait nos
élèves abondent les manifestations qui
ont eu lieu et notamment celle du 11
novembre dernier
allusion directe à la manifestation de
jean marie le pen à carpentras et même
si le front national n'est pas montrée
du doigt la piste d'extrême droite
apparaît très être aujourd'hui la bonne
mais dans la ville prudence
on hésite encore à y croire parce visa
raisons que chacun se rend comme ça
d'impôts bidart tant d'années pour que
la vérité le père 1
si célèbre
car ici la piste des zones fils de bonne
famille aura indéniablement laissé des
marques une piste qui impliquait le
propre fils du maire de carpentras la
sphère du cimetière ces six ans c'est de
toute manière si un de trop ces six ans
d'excès citizen famille
ces six ans où la cité a été bafouée et
j'espère que la cité ont droit sans
honneur des soupçons que jean claude
andrieu espère voir balayer une fois
pour toutes tout comme le juge
d'instruction sylvie motte
c'est elle qui instruit le dossier
pendant six ans avant qu'on ne lui
retire soulagé oui parce que j'ai eu des
pressions terribles
les rumeurs les plus folles ont couru
sur des carpentrassiens et
je n'avais aucune charge contre ces gens
là je ne pouvais rien dire étant tenu
par l'article 11 du code de procédure
pénale dans un certain sens c'est un
soulagement pour moi parce que je me dis
que peut-être là j'avais raison examen
en l'absence de charges en plus pas
mettre en examen
donc j'ai toujours eu le souci d'une
bonne application du code de procédure
pénale est donc là quelque part c'est
une satisfaction pour moi pas d'amertume
chez le juge note juste la satisfaction
de six années de travail peut être enfin
récompensé et surtout le soulagement de
ne pas s'être trompé
six ans après on est donc revenu à la
piste qui avait été privilégié dès le
début cette de l'extrême droite
certaines des personnes interpellées
sont en effet très proche d'un
groupuscule néo nazi
le pn et feu le parti nationaliste
français et européens précision michaël
darmon couleur brune à chaque réunion du
parti nationaliste français et européens
on affiche tout de suite ses idées
l'admiration pour le troisième reich
la suprématie de la race blanche la
violence politique fondée en 1985 par
claude cornilleau aixois et ses ex crown
ationale le pnf le prototype français de
la formation néo-nazie nous ne sommes
pas un parti démocratique dont je tends
la démocratie et la société multiraciale
la démocratie parce qu'elle produit les
mêmes mots dans tous les pays d'europe
le pnf compte environ 500 militants
répartis sur toute la france
on y trouve des étudiants et aussi des
skinheads ces derniers vivent en bande
prenant la violence est alors peu
politisé le pnf ne va leur fournir un
argumentaire et des gestes rituels
blanche dans les tous munis les juifs
jedi noir aujourd'hui on peut trouver
les écrits et le programme du pnl feu
dans les librairies d'extrême droite
bien connu des services de police le
groupuscule néo-nazi poursuite encore
ses activités bien d'autres activités
qui sont pas exercées en propre par le
téléphone et par qu'une cornillon son
fondateur qui sont des activités de
vente de même le tri néo nazis par
correspondance affaire dans laquelle ils
étaient condamnés d'ailleurs l'année
dernière et puis il ya les camps d'été a
dit rassemblement avec des groupes
étrangers notamment le npd allemand ou
des groupes suisses
les profanateurs de carpentras
appartenait à la mouvance keane à
l'époque des fêtes
aujourd'hui ils se disent peiner feu
claude cornilleau le fondateur de ce
parti néo nazi affirme aujourd'hui ne
pas les connaît réaction de jack lang
cette affaire montre à quel point la
propagande de l'extrême droite est
criminogène
le président de sos racisme est encore
plus direct fodé sylla affirme en effet
que jean marie le pen a du sang sur les
mains
le front national devrait réagir demain
à l'occasion d'une conférence de presse
un violent incendie a ravagé cette nuit
il l est du palais de justice de bastia
qui abrite notamment les services des
archives ce sinistre est pour l'instant
d'origine encore indéterminée
reportage yannick a aussi du sien tissu
quelques volutes de fumée se dégage tu
encore mais ce soir l'incendié
complètement éteint première inspection
dans les combles du palais de justice
pour les pompiers qui constate une
nouvelle fois l'étendue des dégâts
les inspecteurs de la police judiciaire
les avaient précédés mais l' enquête
pour déterminer l'origine de l'incendié
ne fait que commencer
je n'ai pas dit à son mari d'en avant de
pouvoir se faire une opinion sur la
sorégies classant dit il faut attendre
côté experts qui vont venir du continent
via des pollens et son capteur pour
l'instant aucune hypothèse at what he
est écarté au fil du potage la droite at
privilégie les archives stockées sous
les combles les cabinets d'instruction à
l'étagé du dessous le parquet encore un
étage plus bas
tous ces services ont été rudement
touché de nombreux dossiers sont
détruits et des dégâts des zooms sur qui
ont abîmé sassano conseillère vanuxem
enfin pour l'essentiel tout a été sauvé
pour les partis qui n'ont pas été
endommagés par le feu
recenser tout ce qui a été endommagé
trouver 400 m² de locaux pour reloger le
personnel assurer la sécurité du
bâtiment
tels sont ce soir en dehors de l'enquète
les premières priorités de la justice il
faudra ensuite procédé au déblaiement
fiso réparation
les travaux de reconstruction devraient
durer au moins deux ans
le sb la maladie de la vache folle
semble transmissibles de la vache aux
veaux la menace est très faible
statistiquement une change rien aux
mesures décidées pour protéger les
consommateurs mais cette information
révélée d'ailleurs par des scientifiques
britanniques pourraient hypothéquer les
chances de la grande bretagne d'obtenir
une levée rapide de l'embargo reportage
patrice gaulle et georges en scène cette
étude britannique a débuté il ya sept
ans sur près de 600 animaux sains ou
infectés une conclusion s'impose une
vache peut dans certains cas transmettre
la maladie à son veau met dans de très
faible proportion 1% en moyenne les
britanniques viennent de communiquer
l'information à bruxelles
mais aucune mesure de contrôle
supplémentaire ne sera prise
outre-manche la transmission ne se
produit pas dans des proportions assez
importante pour en contenir l'épidémie
dans les troupeaux ça n'a pas
d'incidence sur la santé humaine et donc
ça ne justifie pas des modifications
dans les réglementations de santé
publique en france les scientifiques se
doutait bien que la transmission vaches
veaux étaient possibles le comité sur
l'étude de la maladie on avait
d'ailleurs tenu compte l'embargo imposé
à la grande-bretagne concerner aussi les
veaux alors aujourd'hui le ministre de
l'agriculture affiche sa sérénité
cette étude n'apporte rien par rapport
aux précautions que nous avons prises je
dirais même que compte tenu de la
faiblesse des statistiques telles
qu'elles ressortent de l'étude
britannique
nous avons toute raison de penser
qu'effectivement nous opposons aux
consommateurs une viande qui ne présente
aucun risque à bruxelles aucune mesure
particulière n'a été annoncée
aujourd'hui pourtant cette étude aura
sans doute une conséquence la maladie
devrait être plus longue à éradiquer
de nombreux jeunes bovins peuvent être
maintenant suspecté d'infection en
grande bretagne la levée de l'embargo
pourrait donc être repoussée
jacques chirac a reçu à l'elysée son
ancien rival pour la présidentielle
edouard balladur pour un déjeuner privé
déjeuner très privé car les journalistes
ont été tenus à l'écart dans un
communiqué la présidence de la
république a précisé que l'entrevue
entre ses amis 30 ans s'était déroulée
dans une atmosphère très cordiale seules
informations précises de la volaille
étaient au menu en plat principal
les deux hommes ont plus que
probablement évoqué la dégradation du
climat économique avec la nouvelle
hausse du chômage enregistrée au mois de
juin
coïncidence plutôt malheureuse le même
jour le ministre du travail jacques
barrot a annoncé une coupe de 20
milliards de francs dans les divers
systèmes des dalles embauches avec
notamment un recentrage dès cet automne
du fameux ses yeux le contrat initiative
emploi précisions laurent bailly des
petits boulots en petits boulots
on cherche une entreprise qui va pouvoir
regarder en fait y en a pas
comme elle ils sont aujourd'hui plus de
600 mille jeunes en france qui pointe à
l'anpe
les chiffres publiés hier plus 22 milles
800 demandeurs d'emploi en juin confirme
la hausse du chômage déjà enregistré en
mai en dépit des efforts menés en faveur
de l'emploi c'est pourtant le moment que
choisit le ministre du travail pour
faire le ménage dans les aides à
l'emploi qui constitue aujourd'hui un
maquis d'une soixantaine de mesures
accumulés au fil des gouvernements
successifs
objectif réaliser 20 milliards
d'économies avec des aides moins
nombreuses mais plus ciblées exemple
avec le contrat initiative emploi le
fameux ses yeux en 97 les patrons qui
recrutent des chômeurs de longue durée
seront toujours exonéré de charges
pendant deux ans mais ils ne toucheront
les deux mille francs de frais mensuels
que si l'embauché était au chômage
depuis plus de trois ans autre mesure
d'économie
les employeurs qui utilisent les
contrats emploi solidarité les crs
devront désormais en prendre 10% à leur
charge
quant à l'aide pour le premier emploi
des jeunes elle sera tout simplement
supprimées et les stages financés par
l'état diminueront de 50000 l'an
prochain à l'arrivée ce toilettage
risque d'être insuffisant pour endiguer
la hausse du nombre des chômeurs + 135
milles sur un an
car les experts ne sont pas très
optimiste pour l'an prochain aux états
unis près de cinq jours après l'attentât
qui a endeuillé les jeux olympiques
d'atlanta
les enquêteurs du fbi ya eu
manifestement sous pression pour aboutir
avant la fin de ces jeux affirme tenir
plusieurs bonnes pistes la principale
étant semble-t-il richard gmail un
ancien policier de 33 ans qui est
devenue la personne la plus épié des
états unis reportage de nos envoyés
spéciaux
thierry kurt éclos paris
richer jim webb est chez lui l'amérique
entière le sait les agents du fbi qui
ont perquisitionné son domicile en dîner
hier au soir
selon cnn ils ont commandé 20 pips
depuis dix jours toutes les caméras
américaines sont pointés vers atlanta
désormais l'homme le plus connu de ces
jeux est un simple agent de sécurité à
la radio dans la rue des voix commencent
à s'élever mondiale que décidément trop
c'est trop on sait tout de lui de son
passé on y trouve itinéraire de l'ancien
policier frustré qui est allé d'échec en
échec son ancien supérieur va même
jusqu'à nous distribuer son dossier
personnel
on y découvre qu'il a démissionné après
avoir embouti deux voitures de police
son chef mais alors le transformer en
gardiens de prison lui a préféré
démissionner
compte tenu de ce qui s'est passé avec
les véhicules de patrouille on a fait en
sorte tous les maux ne pigez touchée
avait-il le droit d'avoir une arme en
tant que gardien de prison
les armes ce n'était pas le problème
mais je ne crois pas qu'il ait gardé en
prison
héros ou criminelles pour l'instant
chargé wells 7
mais en voulant médiatiser son rôle a
permis aux télévisions américaines de
faire de son histoire un véritable
feuilleton même innocent il n'aura plus
qu'à quitter l'habit ne
et dans l' enquête sur la destruction du
boeing de la twh au large de new york le
directeur du fbi a affirmé aujourd'hui
n'avoir toujours pas les preuves
crédibles tangible d'un acte criminel
notamment l'analyse des débris du boeing
n'a pas permis de mettre en évidence des
traces d'explosifs mais en privé les
experts affirment qu'une défaillance
technique serait tout à fait surprenante
c'est un accueil digne d'un chef d'état
qu'a reçue en rentrant au pays sa rabat
la vague and cette jeune adolescente
philippines condamné à mort aux émirats
arabes unis pour le meurtre de son
employeur qui avait tenté de la violer
cette condamnation à mort avait été
commuée ensuite en peine de prison sous
la pression de l'opinion publique
internationale
sarah a bénéficié hier d'une libération
anticipée
après trois mois de procès à rome le
tribunal militaire a reconnu l'ancien
capitaine ss eric que plus que coupable
d'avoir participé en mars 44 à un
massacre qui avait coûté la vie à 335
italiens
mais les juges lui ont accordé des
circonstances atténuantes ce qui lui
permet d'être libre immédiatement
dorothée olliéric le procès de l'ancien
capitaine nazis eric kripke aura duré
trois mois après trente audience et 170
heures de débat le verdict est tombé
cet après midi le tribunal reconnaît
pris le coup paraît avoir pris part au
massacre de 335 civils italiens pendant
la deuxième guerre mondiale
mais les juges l'ont disculpé des
accusations de cruauté et de
préméditation
estimant qu'il n'avait fait qu'obéir aux
ordres frites que est donc coupable mais
son avocat le lui confirme grâce aux
circonstances atténuantes
il est libre eric triple aujourd'hui 83
ans risquait la réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité pour ça le massacre le 23
mars 1944 des 335 otage italien exécuté
dans les fosses ardéatines des grottes
dans la banlieue sud de rome tripes que
lé reconnu avoir fusillé lui même deux
des victimes pour les familles comme
pour la communauté rhinite aliens la
libération de l'ancien officier nazi
est ce qu'on a dû
les cris des larmes des insultes toute
l'indignation de ceux qui n'ont jamais
oublié une des plus terribles page de
l'histoire en déplacement en algérie
hervé de charette s'est rendu cet après
midi au monastère de tibéhirine pour se
recueillir sur la tombe des sept moines
trappistes français assassiné en mai par
le gia geste éminemment symbolique au
terme d'un voyage très très politique
précisions avec notre envoyé spécial
verdict avant le temps fort de la visite
d'hervé de charette à hadj et la
rencontre en début d'après-midi à la
présidence un entretien très politique
définie entre autres à effacer la
polémique qui avait suivi l'annulation
de la rencontre prévue à new york en
octobre dernier entre jacques chirac et
liamine zeroual depuis celui ci a été
légitimée par l'élection présidentielle
algérienne et une page des relations
entre paris et alger tourné à l'issue de
son entretien de plus d'une heure avec
le président algérien
hervé de charette n'a pas caché sa
satisfaction je fait part de la volonté
politique de la france de faire en sorte
que les relations franco algériennes
prennent un nouveau départ
qu'elle soit fondée sur les principes du
respect mutuel de l'intérêt commun
français et à diana et de la
concertation étroite sur toutes les
questions qui nous concernent des
maisons d'établir le dialogue relancer
la collaboration franco algérienne la
mission qu'ils avaient de charette
s'était fixés en venant ici
à l'issue de sa visite de 24 heures le
ministre des affaires étrangères s'est
déclaré totalement satisfait entre paris
et alger on parle maintenant d'une
étroite collaboration
même si beaucoup d'hôteliers ou encore
de restaurateurs se lamente de la baisse
de fréquentation la côte d'azur reste un
eldorado pour de très nombreux touristes
français bien sûr mais aussi étrangers
notamment des anciens pays de l'est
témoin ce reportage d'olivier theron et
de didier beaumont dans un camping qui
compte près de 20% de polonais qui
vivent pratiquement en autarcie
seuls les coups de soleil sont made in
france
au menu des génies haqiqa pastas aouate
qu'à préparer comme au pays
et pour accompagner ce plat typiquement
polonais le borj chez borné à un potage
de betteraves aux pattes toute la
nourriture ou presque vient directement
de pologne pourtant nous sommes au pays
de l'huile d'olive sur la côte d'azur
les polonais veulent bien payer le
paysage mais pas plus le prix d'un
séjour ici c'est le prix d'un salaire
royal et c'est à dire en fringues
français 1200 francs à peu près malgré
tout les polonais sont venus en masse
des halles et entière de ce camping sont
réservées toute la saison
ni les 48 heures d'autocar ni les tarifs
élevés non plus les entraîner vers
d'autres destinations
une bénédiction pour le camping qui
compense ainsi une saison plutôt morose
nous on travaille essentiellement donc
avec des polonais des hongrois et des
tchèques
on en est en train d'essayer nouer des
contacts avec des tour opérators russe
donc c'est vrai que pour les 10 15 ans à
venir
il faut se tourner vers ces vers ces
pays là parce qu'ils ne connaissent pas
la côte d'azur ils n'ont pas vu au même
titre que les des populations allemandes
hollandaises anglaises ou italiennes qui
viennent déjà de plus beaucoup plus
longtemps
les touristes de l'est qui représentent
20% de la clientèle du camping ne
dépenserons que très peu d'argent au
cours de leur séjour à peine plus de
1000 francs il est vrai qu'à europa
bleach le soleil et la mer sont gratuits
avant de mettre le cap vers atlanta pour
le journal des jeux un mot de football
avec des nouvelles de notre papin
nationale qui a signé aujourd'hui un
contrat de deux saisons était girondins
de bordeaux l'ancien attaquant du bayern
s'est dit soulagé et heureux de revenir
au pays
joie partagé par christophe du scion
c'est un retour en france
un retour en grâce et bientôt peut-être
un retour gagnant jpp reviens c'est le
retour de jean pierre papin
cet après midi il a signé son contrat ce
matin il a signé des autographes et ceux
qui pensaient que jpp difficulté
guignol est un footballeur finis se sont
mis un ballon de foot dans la vie
j'espère déjà apporté
mon expérience ma fraîcheur parce que
j'ai pas vu depuis longtemps j'ai envie
de jouer je me sens en pleine forme je
fais la préparation que le bailleur
depuis un mois un mois et demi et donc
après le test positif ce matin je me
sens très bien
bon pour le service d'un point de vue
médical on va peut-être retrouver le
papa de marseille
le j pp flingueurs partir de première et
techniciens de surface de réparation
il ya un mois et demi papin était déjà
venu à bordeaux pour la finale de la
coupe de l'uefa
prince de l'élégance il avait même salué
les bordelais battus par son club
d'alors le bayern de munich après quatre
ans d'absence jean pierre papin revient
en france et c'est tant mieux
absolument dans un instant le journal
des jeux en direct d'atlanta le temps de
vous rappeler votre rendez vous avec
florent dauffy pour le dernier journal
en principe vers minuit et demi entre
deux épreuves olympiques
à demain bonsoir